- [Narrator] With more than 65,000
square feet of space and 115 rooms,
Hearst Castle is one of America's
largest and most treasured homes.
(dramatic piano music)
Hearst Castle was built by
American newspaper magnate
William Randolph Hearst in 1919
after he inherited
40,000 acres of farmland.
He would go on to purchase
200,000 more acres of land,
allowing him to create
the kind of sprawling
compound rarely seen to this day.
In addition to the main
house, La Casa Grande,
Hearst Castle is comprised
of three guest houses,
an outdoor pool, and
numerous other amenities.
One of the most recognizable
rooms in the Hearst Castle
is the 345,000 gallon indoor Roman pool.
Styled after Ancient Roman baths,
the pool is decorated with eight statues
of Roman and Greek gods,
goddesses, and heroes.
Hearst was known for
throwing lavish parties,
and hosting important figures
at his San Simeon home.
Winston Churchill, Charlie
Chaplin, Cary Grant,
Greta Garbo, and Calvin Coolidge
were some of the hundreds of house guests.
The home was donated to the
State of California in 1958,
and welcomes more than
750,000 visitors every year.